if you are watching this then you have
just finished Final Fantasy and you
probably desperately want to talk about
it or hear people talk about it is that
kind of game don't worry we're here for
you this is game spots Final Fantasy 7
remake spoiler cast I am John Luke
psyche and I am joined by two more
Huseyin hi Phil Horne Shaw Hey
and Nick Sherman hey guys we were all
people who had it in the office little
early played through the game and yeah
we're just gonna basically talk about
everything that happened in the game
it's a lot I think a good way to start
this would be to kind of go through and
get everyone's basic opinion of the game
as well as maybe your experience with
Final Fantasy to start with I never
played Final Fantasy 7 I think I was the
only person who got it who didn't play
the original game so I have a fairly
unique perspective but to my surprise I
ended up loving this game what about you
Phil I'm also a really big fan of this
game I had a great time I played Final
Fantasy 7 way back in 1997 when it came
out and it was you know had a really big
impact on me as a person who really
likes story and video games it was one
of the first times that I like really
encountered a game that really went hard
on story like that
made me a big squaresoft RPG fan for the
next few years after that so I've been
looking forward to this kind of in a
cautiously optimistic way because I feel
like a lot of those games haven't really
aged well that I used to love but I had
I had an awesome time I thought it was
exactly what I wanted
Final Fantasy 7 to be it was like the
way I wish that Final Fantasy 7 had been
told and like played in 1997 this is
that game and the way that expands on
the characters especially is just
awesome I had a great time
heck yeah what about you Nick so like
you feel I played it back in 1997 and I
think back then it took me like a year
to beat it because I was just a kid but
it's been my favorite game of all time
since then
I think it was the first game that I
played that really cemented the belief
that video games could be more than just
platformers because back then I just
been playing song to had job in Crash
Bandicoot so I can assured Lisa I would
not be here where I am without Final
Fantasy 7 and I beat it earlier this
week and like you I loved it as well I
didn't love everything they did but it's
still I mean it's obviously my favorite
game of this year so far considering
it's only April but it was everything I
wanted it to be and more
I can't believe to say this but it lived
up to my expectations
very curious what you all think of the
ending we'll get we'll get into that in
a bit I imagine but yeah it's a it's
something else ok yeah happy to have you
on this I know your your your this is
your first time being on a podcast like
this we had you on because you're just
such a huge fan in the office your your
love for this game I feel like always
shines through it is a very full circle
moment for me that's for sure yeah
and then tomorrow I feel like I imagine
most people listening to this probably
know what you think since you reviewed
the game but for those who haven't why
don't you let them know yeah so my
experience with Final Fantasy 7 is it's
probably the last of the classics I
played I grew up in a environment where
a lot of the games that I was first
exposed to were through watching other
people play specifically my cousins and
I watched them play eight first of all
there was the first one I saw them but
they always had posters for Final
Fantasy 7 in their room I never played
it myself so I became a fan of Final
Fantasy through 8 and which I know is
going to be controversial because people
have different opinions of a pile of a
my first personal final fantasy that I
got and played on my own without you
know being shepherded by a family member
was 9 and it remains one of my favorites
and I think my love of seven is from
from of 8 and 9 kind of just I felt
responsible to play 7 and I played 7 and
I played it quite a long time after it
was available launched sorry and
I loved it there was a lot of heart in
that game and it's it's a game that
sticks stuck with me and like Nick said
it's one of the games that contribute to
the idea that you know games could be
more and it was something that I wanted
to continue thinking about so it's it's
one of the formative games in my life as
well and I've been a fan of various
entries in that series since at the very
least I've paid attention to the series
and the franchise since and obviously my
opinions of this game are document and
they're a matter of record at this point
I gave it a ten out of ten
imagine a lot of people are gonna be
wondering why I gave it 10 out of 10 and
I don't think we'll get too deep into
that here but you can read the review on
GameSpot calm you can watch the video
review which Sean leaper magnificent
edit of together on on YouTube you can
also check out the game support after
dark podcast where we talk about it as
well in the segments at length and I
believe there should be a small video
around that specific discussion point
coming out soon but so if I had to say
that I give it and I loved it it's met
my expectations and in love regards
exceeded them fantastic yeah to clarify
I think I really or I said I don't if I
said I didn't play a Final Fantasy or I
just didn't say seven play seven I did
my first Final Fantasy was actually
thirteen and I I feel like that has
colored my opinion of the series every
sense because I never finished it and
there are things about that game I like
but there's a lot about it I didn't like
and then I kind of bounced off fifteen
as well so I wasn't really expecting
this game to uh to grab me you know but
like it really did and I'm I'm still
trying to parse out why it is but I
think it I really appreciate how from a
story perspective the game does a really
good job introducing you to its world
compared to maybe some other final
fantasies where you like like I just all
I remember about thirteen was like that
game it's just throwing
terms and like exposition at you and it
none of its stuck with me and I really
love how this one was very simple a very
like straightforward setup and then at
the end it gets into like the final
fantasy [ __ ] but like at that point
I was like already hooked into the
characters and invested in the world so
when that happened I was like alright
you know what I'm here for it I've
already invested take me on your insane
final fantasy journey at the end there
so yeah why don't we start with just
sort of the why do we talk about some of
the changes because that that has been
the most interesting thing for me
talking with you guys is hearing how
much was added and how much was
different the the sort of the social
commentary around you know the nature of
avalanche and their fight against Shinra
like that stuff's all in the original
from what you guys have been telling me
but it wasn't into nearly the same
degree yeah it's well it's just a deeper
story in a big way right so we're
getting more of like the on-the-ground
stuff there's a lot more time and
attention spent with an avalanche in
general and like the the side characters
Biggs wedge and Jesse are like a horse
great part of this game yeah they're
great right there they're really really
minor in in the original game and also
it's worth noting that the remake turns
of what was like five to eight hours of
the original game into a forty hour
stretch so it's it's filling out a lot
of that time mostly with character
development and it's all really good but
so you spend a lot more time with the
Avalanche characters you spend a lot
more time in Midgar in different places
kind of getting a sense of how people
feel about what's going on after you
blow up the reactor and all that stuff
it all just feels more realistic and and
heavier you know like you blow up this
reactor and in in the remake like you
spend the next three or so hours kind of
dealing with the aftermath of that and
how everybody feels about it and not
just the people who were there
but people watching it on TV people who
are like living next door and maybe got
their houses smashed or you know people
who are looking for people who are
missing it all feels like much more like
how real people would react and it just
it really like makes all that stuff that
is kind of conceptual in the original
game because you're kind of burning past
it I'm much faster rate it makes it feel
much much more like in your face it's a
bigger part of the story or cuz it could
be realized right like you go look back
at those old graphics and it's Lester's
yet you can't capture like the emotion
of a moment through the phases of that
like really early CG right yeah I don't
know I feel like you can capture stick
because there are other you know RPG
experiences contemporary at that time or
even gaming experience though
contemporary for that time that did
capture a feeling I think that um I
think you're right in that they they
definitely face limitations but at the
same time I don't want to talk it all up
to just that because just the quality in
writing would be in this remake would be
undersold to an extent okay yeah yeah I
mean I mean not to like diminish well
you said a hundred seven agree with it
like the cinematic and visual elements
of walking through you know the that
sector after you've blown up a massive
reactor there wouldn't have hit as hard
and you do have small elements of that
you have like a couple of buildings that
are on fire in the original but as a
whole it's it doesn't it's not it's not
an event it's not an inciting incident
that's quickly swept under the rug in
the way that is in the original like
they move on from that they treat that
as a setup for a much bigger story
whereas in this game it is the story
instead of all of it and what makes it
more hit harder is actually the writing
itself is more thoughtful and it feels
more considered they they kind of breeze
past it and I described it in my review
as a hop skip and I jump back to seventh
heaven with the bar where you know
avalanche is hiding out and is their
hideout but they
do that here they kind of spend a little
more time and they use their they use
their mop modern but like more advanced
writing abilities to really dig a little
deeper and I feel like that's an
important part of this game and that
moment specifically I completely agree
yeah it's super good like a big part of
that whole discussion is jesse is the
one who makes the bombs for avalanche
and after the reactor bombing it ends up
being like much more devastation than
they expected and there are story
reasons for that but which we just say
well yeah we could look at its the
Shinra guys it's a it's a false flag
attack like the bomb was supposed to
damage the reactor Shinra at the end of
the bombing mission in Chapter one you
watch them like turn all their guns on
the reactor and blow it up bigger
basically to scapegoat Abilene you know
you know what I really like they never
find that out 1300 find it out where
where Jesse finds out that that's what
happened because oh not to say that that
wouldn't diminish her feelings but like
it's sort of like it still had to stick
with her and so such a good choice such
a good choice - not for her to never
find that out she said it informs her
character for the entire rest of the
game that she thinks she got killed all
those people it's it's yeah this it's
funny because I that's what I thought
was gonna happen
I thought during like the pillar
collapse scene like Reno or Roode would
let it slip and that would be like
Jesse's lasting thought was like oh it
wasn't me like I can I can die easily
now but no you're right like she goes to
the grave with it it's so good and
that's that's the kind of thing where I
think everyone here knows but like just
in case someone who isn't familiar with
us is listening like we love anime to
different degrees here but like that's
the kind of anime type writing you'd
expect from final fantasy where you know
a character is give absolved of their
sins or they they perceive sins to
themselves so that you can have this
triumphant moment or even like a moment
of dying happy this this felt like very
unexpected and very I felt like the same
way with you guys I was like yeah she's
gonna find out that she wasn't to blame
for this but they never do that do that
they
just leave it lingering in it and it
kind of eats at her as a person and it
informs who she is and every decision
she makes from that point on which is
just really the kind of writing nuance
and and thinking that past main line
Final Fantasy games haven't trained us
to expect from the series um if you're
more familiar with like the MMO then
perhaps you would be a little more
inclined to it but that doesn't that's a
silo team that's working you know under
alongside a very talented specific
writer who's been working on that world
for a really long time this is just it
is a bit of a out of nowhere shot in the
dark kind of feeling with the kind of
sensitivity and the smarts and the
layers which they approach
characterization in this game even
characters that feel made one more
one-dimensional at first like rude and
Reno was that his name mm-hmm the other
one the the Turks like there's they have
a couple of scenes where they don't feel
great about what they did and like
they're still villains but like I
appreciated that it wasn't they weren't
a hundred percent just like I'm the bad
anime villain like there is that moment
of humanity in there but they're also
like I don't know that was my job and
like I did what you know I was told to
do but like they're kind of planting
those seeds for maybe those characters
to develop later on but I like I yeah it
just feels like every character that
like could have been one-dimensional
feels a little bit more nuanced except
for maybe that doctor guy Oh Joe
okay so Joe he's maybe a little more
like classic anime like even his
appearance is like very like goofy yeah
yeah I mean it definitely has its it's
comically evil villains but the ones who
are like closer to the protagonists and
like more in on the action a lot more
often are much more interesting people
and this game definitely like puts the
work in to make them even as they're
doing bad stuff like to make them
interesting to to be around
yeah how'd y'all kind of then that the
story needs him to be that character be
almost like one-dimensional because you
can't really like if you try to humanize
him in any other way it wouldn't work
like you can't come up with a good
reason for taking this you know ancient
and trying to experiment and you know
doing these heinous things it needs to
be that character especially with the
way things unfold in the future and the
way they fill out the whole Joe's
backstory but like you said I think like
even even like other characters who are
similar or kind of charismatic and in
like Heidegger for example is another
kind of very not by numbers but like
very plainly villainous character and
play to play 211 but on purpose but you
kind of need that because Shinra himself
is is like an ambivalent cold lack of
empathy kind of character so if he was
the core focus it wouldn't the villain
side of it wouldn't sell until late in
the game where he's like you know making
big proclamations so Heidegger needs to
be that character to show why behind
that behind Shinra is coldness cold evil
there's an actual maniacal evil pushing
as well yeah so do we want to get into I
guess I am curious from you guys what
would be what was like your favorite
thing that they added or changed because
like you said they took like that what
five hours and they stretched it to
thirty to forty hours like what were the
moments that you think like in this
remake like benefited I guess a Nick
that's such a good question
like there's they're really so many of
them I I loved I loved the scene where
you're climbing you're climbing up the
destroyed structures up to get to the
Shinra building that was like a little
minigame in the original we had to like
buy the batteries from the weapon shop
and climb up the wire and then like do
this little swinging bar minigame where
you had to time your jump at the right
time and it was like a three minute long
section but now it's
it's like an hour and a half and you're
just climbing up and there's this
beautiful sunset and you you know you're
talkin of the the plate falling and just
kind of reinforces all the steaks that
that sticks out in my mind really well
there are a lot of little things they
did over the course of the game like
like the Hell House for example like
bringing that back as a surprise
bossfight oh my god that's I having no
context for that I was like yeah what is
happening holy crap absolutely so good
like they do that with a lot of
characters or a lot of enemies I should
say like a lot of the mini bosses or
bosses in general used to be just random
encounters in the Shinra building for
example like that that like flying snake
thing with swords on its sides like that
flying centipede or whatever I use just
be a random enemy that would that would
appear from time to time yeah and even
even stuff like the behemoth just being
hidden in the kind of like a side quest
that's a good throwback as well
I was probably jump in here as well and
say like one of my favorite changes is a
speak so what Nicholas enters so many
but the smaller things seem to hit
harder than the way harder than the
bigger ones like so during one part you
you're speaking to the teacher at the
orphanage and she mentions the
everything she she's obviously like very
caring of these kids and has her own
ambitions elsewhere but she mentions
everything she learns is from someone
else that used to work at the orphanage
and you don't really they don't like
tell you immediately but later on you
learned that it's Biggs and you're just
like oh I make that connection you're
like oh you used to work at an orphanage
and then it becomes more overt where he
kind of towards the end of the game he
actually named checks the orphanage and
says hey can you do this for me that's
such an amazing moment like and that's
just not in the original at all right
now one of those really cool things that
happened sometimes from playing a video
game to where there's no side quest that
pops up after that that's like go back
to the orphanage and
tell them about bigs but I went back
there myself just to see if there would
be some kind of dialogue because I
wanted I wanted to do that was like oh I
found out about you like I want to tell
you guys what happened to Biggs yeah but
no I don't think there was anything any
option there and that's the thing like
the the the impulse to go back and try
and see if how much of the world has
been affected by your own knowledge and
your own feelings like there's no the
game never creates an expectation like
Mass Effect where you the more you speak
to characters after you do these
significant moments that their dialog
will change right like in the Mass
Effect you do a big mission and you come
back and everyone has something new to
say they do everyone has a comment on
what has just happened that's not this
type of game but yet the thoughts and
feeling feelings that inspire still
compels you to go there and do that and
want that which i think is a testament
to the strength of the writing and the
characterization itself that you know
after every major event in the game I
want it to speak to people and speak to
characters and be like oh you know how
do you feel about this thing happening
to arathor how do you feel about this
major event that just happened but it's
it's not there but it doesn't need to be
because it kind of works as is if you
get one saying yeah yeah totally
especially because like I find I did not
know this but like Phil you've been kind
of discovering that like there are
actual like things that do affect the
game that if the game doesn't make a
parent which like like the different
dresses and like you are you were
mentioning like there's a alternate
side-quests yeah there's so I think the
dress alter the alternate dresses was a
thing from the original I can't remember
exactly what how that all worked out but
I remember you know based on your
performance in certain places you'd get
different dresses and that whole system
is here - we I've just been trying to
figure out what it is and I think I
finally have a handle on it
it's SciQuest related by the way but
yeah and then in chapter 9 in the wall
market apparently your choices in
talking with like chocobo Sam or
if you run into Johnny at that one point
and like follow him back and get the
sign of that scene of him at the
honeybee all that stuff effects what
side missions you get later in the
chapter so and then that effects how you
get the dresses so there it's kind of
under the hood the game's not real
explicit about it and it takes some like
experimentation to figure out all that
stuff out but it's there and it's
interesting and there are actually now
that I think about it there are actually
a bunch of little story deviations along
the way that I have noticed going back
and replaying chapters for instance your
performance on the bike in Chapter four
with Jesse changes that scene pretty
significantly afterward oh really
dialogue yeah she's just got a bunch of
different dialogue and the way she
treats you changes a little bit you know
like she's kind of putting on a whole
act the entire time with flirting with
Clara with cloud you know it's it's yeah
it's like a defense mechanism but the
degree to which she's engaging that and
like how sincere she is definitely
shifts based on like say how how well
you do on the driving and stuff like
that so there are little things around
at little scenes you can miss if you
like in the collapsed Expressway I
caught one that I had missed before to
where if you come up to the edge of a
gap you can't cross before you find the
ladder to circumvent it like I had
missed this I just had gone down the
ladder and but there's a little scene
between cloud and Aerith and they have
like a little conversation and it's like
man there's just a ton of little story
bits and they're all characterization
moments that are scattered throughout
the game that you could totally walk
past and never see and so every time I
keep going back to just like do guides
and stuff I'm finding little tidbits
that kind of enrich the experience yeah
I think all the little character
dialogue in in-between like in the I
guess quote dungeon areas like you know
you're just wandering through doing
combat but in between each fight there
is always like a new piece of dialogue
that a character will say that's just
like adds to the world that I just like
it made those areas feel like so
compelling
and like that's always been like my
favorite kind of stuff in games it's
like small little bits of extra dialogue
that like really fill things out Phil
what was what would you say was your
favorite like a new moment I really
loved both things that you guys
mentioned I think I'm actually gonna
write an article about this I'm like
half way through it
but all of chapter four I think might be
my favorite
it's just biggs and wedge and Jesse
you go to Jesse's house and like see her
dad in his hospital bed which is a
result of like a Shinra accident and you
just learned all this stuff about all
the characters through the course of
this mission it's all just super good
yeah like you get the sense of their
teamwork and the way that they interact
with each other and I don't know I feel
like that's the chapter that really sold
me on the game if I'm being honest like
I played the demo which is chapter one
and like there are some clunky lines in
that demo you know if there's bear it
has simple like stinker lines just he
really does he's just like talking about
the planet and like I'm I'm imagining
being the first person or you know this
is the first time you've played this
game and you're like what the hell is
this guy talking about my exact
experience I start this game up and
Barry is just screaming at me and I'm
like dude shut up like I don't like what
are you going on about yeah right and
like super weird concepts about like
Gaia and lifestream and all the stuff
and you're like what what what are you
talking about but then you get to
chapter 4 and it's just oh hey this is
why it's the why we fight episode
basically right and it's so good yeah I
don't know I just loved all of it I had
a great time that duel with the biker
guy Roche was also he's like comically
ridiculous but I had a great time with
that was deal I don't think what is he
showed up and then left and you never
came back but I kind of loved him like
this grudging respect for you like you
have a whole you have a whole arc of a
relationship with this guy through
fights it's great no I just held me back
though there was like he has that one
line after you beat him where he's like
you and I like our nutter for
potential yet yeah right so like it's
great like saves your life yes I can't
be back in future future future chapters
I think I I'm really interesting where
his all goes cuz he seems like he could
be one of those people that's like you
know what I might just join you right
that that I've kind of thought about
over the years is you know shinra's
under control of this huge army of
soldiers you know literally like that's
there that unless they're at their
company right it's like they're the best
warriors and in the entire world
they are like Sephiroth super powerful
like how come they never employed any
soldiers to attack you and when you were
attacking the Shinra building so like
that was my first thought when I when I
saw Roach was like oh finally like
they're actually showing someone who
like knows how to fight and they're
actually sending in their big dogs yeah
I guess for me because I didn't play the
game my I I didn't have I don't have
like a new moment but the the two
moments that stuck out with me was
chapter chapter 16 which is the Shinra
building when you first go in there
mostly because I was expecting it to
just be this like very straightforward
like fight your way to the top and it
kind of starts that way but then it
completely slows down and you have this
moment where you're just like walking
through the hallways and you're seeing
like people like in their offices and
you're seeing like the corporate like
you know propaganda on like the screens
and you're walking through that like
that museum where they're like
explaining how gender works which I I
really liked that moment I don't know if
that's in the original at all or if it
if it's a little more straightforward
but it felt like this nice like it kind
of slowed it down but in a way that like
it was continuing to sort of build build
out Shinra and the world a little bit in
a way that I I personally really
appreciated also that I did the
staircase and oh my god that what did
not only is that a funny scene but the
way where they have over time you get
these cloud starts walking slower and
slow
because he's getting tired and the
characters are like more out of breath
and like Barrett and cloud are just
upset at each other and then they have
that little like score on I don't know
if you guys on your characters health
screen it has like a score which says
which floor the person's on and when you
go above a floor it like moves that
characters like health bar like above
the other one like like it's a contest
even though it actually doesn't matter I
don't think maybe there's an achievement
for it but yeah it's just such a good
bit if at one point Tifa says like Oh
make sure you cut your breath like I
wonder if you if you pause on a platform
you can like start your whining again
moving faster yeah yeah that's a good
point
red boat I did both those I did both the
staircase and the elevator and they're
different story stuff by the way like
they're both worth doing but yeah I
didn't I didn't mess around with it
enough to like really see the nuances
there no no I want to go back but that's
a lot of lights man yeah it's it's big
they make that joke like I think it
takes like a good five minutes to do it
it's really long but it's really funny
and it's like nice I think this game
strikes such a great balance between
serious and comedy in a way that I think
a lot of game a lot is specific a lot of
Japanese games don't quite work for me
where I think the humor feels a little
too contrasty in with with the the
seriousness of the story but I feel like
here it works where it gives them more
of a reprieve like it like you doesn't
need that break for a minute
which leads which leads to my favorite
moment which is all of chapter 9
woolmarket
I think was just absolutely fantastic
I'm a I'm a huge Yakuza fan as I was
playing this game I was just feeling
like yeah Kooser vibes in terms of like
the way you kind of wander around and
stuff like that and and of course like
woolmarket is just like clearly based on
like you know red-light districts like
Kabukicho from you know Tokyo and and
that whole section was amazing those
care
those different characters the different
what are they called the the like three
the three different heads the trio all
of those characters are so good yeah up
in case three I I do the tree there's so
much I could talk about that we could
talk about the big scene the the cloud
cross-dressing dance no Marion which is
so good can I describe tell me when you
get to the mud you Muppet yeah what's he
talking about like machi Mamaji and then
when like the stage and the band comes
in and I'm like oh okay yeah the grand
from Yakuza 0 this is the mod you man oh
my god it's so good and I think it's
worth highlighting the fact that I think
I want to speak entirely for Phil and
Nick but I got a sense that we're on the
same page like the original does not
handle this very well like it's it's I
would go so far as to say that by modern
standards its problematic and going into
that section I was quite concerned I was
like god I hope they do this again
previous recent mainline Final Fantasies
hasn't given us much to expect any sort
of like progressiveness or even
forward-thinking
that's from from them but man they
nailed it
they of it was after that moment that
like we have a slight channel at work
about the remake and like right after I
saw that scene was when I pitched an
idea that was like how Final Fantasy 7
like quelled my fears of it being too
weird by making making it even weirder
yeah it was it was great I loved it yeah
I think they just handled that so well
like like there's that moment it's more
you and Mia both talked about it like
the final line that I was Andrea is that
his name yeah he says where he basically
says I forget exactly what the line is
but it's something to the effect of like
gender is an illusion and be whoever you
want to be
itself you're comfortable in your you
know dancing is about being comfortable
in yourself or and I and acting like no
one is watching you or judging you and
it's just you know doesn't matter
regardless of gender and and the way the
way they do it is like looking directly
into the camera alright right
the cloud is positioned or your you as
the viewer its position in a way where
it's andreas talking directly to you and
I was just like wow this is this is not
only is this done well but it's done
intentionally right
and what I also really enjoy about that
whole scene is that there's a lot of
humor in it and it's you know it's cross
it's cloud dressing up and a dress and
like oh man but none of that none of the
moments are played as a joke about that
concept they're what what jokes there
are are about the characters themselves
and like how it's just Klaus just
uncomfortable being the center of
attention in any way and like that's
what the joke is they that's the joke
that they make there's even a moment
there's the line that like sold it for
me is when cloud and Tifa reunite inside
Don Carneros mansion and she's like oh
yeah dress your hair and claw goes yeah
I know nailed it moving on like yes but
not only doesn't she
I assumed she knew it was cloud from the
get-go but when he says moving on
there's a pause and then she goes oh
wait your cloud even know it was him she
just was complementing this person on
their amazing outfit yeah yeah it's just
so good like he doesn't make it thing
out of it nobody makes a thing out of it
it's just that it's it's playing off
what we know about the characters and
not in making anybody the butt of a joke
and also like it's not just the writing
of that joke it's the delivery of that
joke and also the framing of that joke
like I mention this on the podcast as
well but there's like a lot that goes
into selling a line like that and one
part of it is the cinematics and like
the way it's framed and they have a new
cinematic director I believe from
previous games from like they had one
that they use across Kingdom Hearts
various other titles and that person has
always been there or has been there for
long enough to work on multiple titles
for Square Enix and they bought someone
new in and you can see that it just
cinematically and in terms of kind of
cinematography it feels like a way way
more way way more interesting and way
better high quality experience and the
the kind of benefit that is lines like
this landing as well as they do because
of the cuts and the closeness of the
camera and the way it and it frames
everyone and the joke and it just lands
perfectly yeah I have a question
actually was Johnny in the original game
I can't remember I don't believe so no I
think I think he was I think um I think
he was in Sector 7 and like just kind of
based on his super low poly model he had
like red red any kind of walk with like
a swagger and I think if you interact
with him his name was Johnny but he's an
NPC he's just he's just there but not
nearly to this extent no yeah I mean I
he kind of starts as like a very classic
just like the goofy I mean he kind of
stays that way they're like goofy in
over his head like doesn't just has no
idea of just how in over his head he is
kind of like anime character he's even
voiced by Yuri Lowenthal who like ways
that kind of character like he's like
I'm just like it's just Yosuke from
persona or like he's just he's all like
he'll always plays those characters but
that a bet side quest where you're
running around him in wall market is
it's just so good like yeah just
constantly getting into trouble with him
and there's like the you meet all these
like they put so much effort in those
like side characters like the chef who
just is like my cooking's not good
anymore and I don't know what it is and
like everybody is like being
hospitalized by this man's cooking and
he's getting no sense of the damage he's
doing to the world
him it's it's awesome the thing I love
about this game the thing that really
sold it for me is the fact that like
there's that amount of effort put into
every single character you interact with
it's so crazy like there's just so much
everybody has just like this elevated
amount of being feeling like a real
character like same thing in woolmarket
would you go talk to the guy at the
materia shop like that whole room is
awesome he's he's a crystal salesman
like we would you know it's a new-age
crystal shop and he's laying down and
it's like the music and everything but
he sells materia Slyke such a good gag
it's straight out of the original - is
it yeah he's like lying down on the side
and he's just like Delhi super young
dude who would sell the magic rocks like
that's so perfect
you mentioned the music which I love how
in woolmarket it's the same theme but
it's dramatically different in each area
so you have like the the materia shop
kind of has that like you said New Age
hippie theme and then there's sort of
like that's the theme that plays outside
of the like the bumble the honey the
honey bee in and then you go to like the
the chocobo stable and it's got this
like real like twang II you know like
western kind of feel like I love the way
they kind of like blend each of those
different themes together which is maybe
just a conversation into how good the
soundtrack is holy crap guys I've been
like I've been listening to this Final
Fantasy soundtrack it's like YouTube was
the thing like I I when I was a kid yeah
yeah CD as well but on the piano
collection is something I still listen
to all the time like if I need to
concentrate on something at work like I
have that playing in the background and
I'm so happy that a new generation is
gonna be able to experience the main
theme and tifa's theme and ahead and
ahead and on our way like when that
starts playing when you get to sector 7
for the first time I just put my
controller down I was like
oh my god yeah I wanted to be the so one
of the original versions of my I
mentioned this earlier we were talking
about how long we played it for and I
was talking about how I was writing my
review and Irish hero 3-3 reviews for
this game and scrapped two of them but
they were almost fully written for each
one of those and the first one I did was
saying my current the current review
that I published ice opens with like a I
kind of recount the bombing mission in
the old in the new game and I took and
tried to compare it and and kind of
frame the nuance that they're trying to
find I originally did that with the
prelude theme at the start just on the
title screen and because when I turned
that game on I was I start it starts off
very familiar and very similar to the
original version and then you just start
hearing the different layers that
they've introduced the different sounds
the different kind of motifs that are
underpinning this song that you're so
intimately familiar with and when I
heard it I remember it gave me chills
and I just listened to it and it kind of
perfectly encapsulated that feeling of
taking this thing that you know this
song that you know and just laying out
all the new ways that they had found to
create depth in there and create make it
more richer and more full-bodied
experience and is the same for like the
entire soundtrack the entire soundtrack
is that it really says something when
somebody like me who never played the
original sigh like shouldn't have any
nostalgia just hearing the soundtrack
like gave me nostalgia for a thing I
don't have nostalgia for you know what I
mean like I've just sitting there being
like oh man this is like sending me back
to my childhood even though I've never
played Final Fantasy 7 and I shouldn't
have any attachment but like it's just
you can tell like how much effort they
put into and making it like just exactly
perfect and like they really wanted to
capture it so good I think I think
another liked it going back to like
small moments resonated with me another
one was hearing the I think was called
like hip hop to chocobo or something
yeah it's under sass
could tell me we're having so much fun
making this game I was like I cannot
believe they turn to chuck about him
into a trap B it's unbelievable good it
goes hard I think it's like when the
choke because there's actual like
chocobo sounds in there like the
chocobos are like mixed in and they're
like screech is like it's a little too
much it's like man this is kind of
terrible but I also can't stop listening
to it I love that soundtrack there's so
many bops on yeah I can't even no I love
that there's an entire in-game
soundtrack that is not part of the
soundtrack that you feel like goodbye
yeah and they're great they're all great
remixes well it's like people giving it
to you to like the the hip hop to
chocobo one is like that guy's like hey
man what's up like you want to hear this
song it's pretty rad and you're like
hands you and tape and you're like what
look it's so weird but it's so good I
there's that one track I don't know what
it's called but it's in the when you do
the shortcut into like the tunnel the
abandoned tunnel dude yes yes this
abandoned tunnel it's visually it's it's
okay but it's not like the most
interesting thing in the game but then
they just put this absolutely pop of a
soundtrack where it's like this like
songs yeah yeah I put it in the review
because I was like I have to get this
song somewhere in because it's so good
and it's just like moments like that
where they're like they take an area
that's like again probably like somewhat
low in terms of like visually compared
to other areas but then they just were
like we'll put in this really awesome
song just to make this area feel great
dude it's crazy okay so that song is
called the oppressed it's the battle
version and that's my least favorite
song from the original soundtrack and
it's my most favorite song this
soundtrack because that's how good it is
like they completely changed my mind
about that song it's so great I'm so
excited for them to start touring with
this as like a live show or something
come on soundtrack to arrive I sprung
for the entire 8 disc 7770 soundtrack as
dollars and 70 cents and yeah I don't
know what it's gonna arrive I think it's
gonna be sometime in the future um so
like a month from now maybe if we're
lucky but I can't wait I'm so excited so
good yeah but I guess the main thing we
want to talk about is the ending right
yeah well before getting to the ending I
guess I'm curious because it is the the
ending the the changes in the ending
that they kind of seed throughout so you
have those weird like the Dementors of
Azkaban showing up how did you guys feel
about that overall as a concept in the
game I'm still processing I think yeah
it's very unexpected yeah and I think
this is the thing that people fans on
the internet are paying the most
attention to and the most sure about in
lot of ways which is understandable yeah
it's very different right like yeah yeah
I don't know some part of it feels
necessary to me there's a lot in this
game that I feel like is so the main
criticisms I've had tweeted at me is
yeah like how why are we paying for a
$40 for a small part of the game and I'm
like okay that game has so much in it
like that is not an argument I roll I
don't I don't engage with with those
those people saying that because it's
just it's not a good faith argument at
all because if you knew anything about
you would know that it's a fully fledged
complete game and I say as much in my
review the other thing they're saying is
like the ending is and the story changes
and I'm one of those people that I'm
like I kind of don't given how thorough
they are in fleshing out the small chunk
of the game that they do explore it
feels necessary that they start making
inroads
into changing the broader story as well
in some meaningful way yeah for like a
good example is sort of from what I've
been told if they had been faithful
Sephiroth wouldn't have even shown up in
this game at all right yeah and they
kind of they see just a little early on
and I feel like that felt as somebody
who like never played it I I appreciated
that because it I'm aware of Sephiroth
you know he's such an iconic villain and
it felt like that was necessary to cede
him throughout the game because it's
setting up kind of cloud story it's
setting up the larger overall story I
forget who but I want to say somebody
here in the office said how this kind of
felt like like like the beginning of
like Star Wars like it kind of feels
like a new hope or where it's like it's
setting up this larger trilogy I guess
but like it feels mmm it's I don't know
like I felt like they properly concluded
and and everything that they were like
the main stuff they were setting up with
the kind of the Battle of Shinra and
Midgar and sort of like the convictions
of the characters and it very much ends
with them feeling like we we now know
what we need to do and we all feel like
setting our convictions and we were
ready to go on this journey but like I
I can't imagine like I feel like they
had to put Sephiroth in like you
couldn't like it would be kind of weird
to just end it without it because you
would be like well what's the
overarching goal like where is this
going you know if you guys thinking
about it I I definitely feel that way I
feel like it's they did using Zephyr off
in a more intelligent way at least as it
stands now because that the way the
story unfolds towards the latter half in
the original becomes very confusing and
it feels a lot of like stuff that's
dumped on you almost it's kind of like
it reminds me of the mentality back when
everyone was trying to create movies
that have a sudden twist that turns
everything is upside down on his head
and all movies were trying to do that
you know I see dead people moment and
that's what that kind of felt like at
the time like it's it seeds it in the
original
different ways but not super effectively
I thought right now it's it's the jobs
that the job that they're trying to do
is make Sephiroth a more menacing and
interesting character from the very
start but also do some justice to the
relationship and there and the kind of
history that cloud and Sephiroth have so
that when they do adhere to the similar
twists towards the end it doesn't feel
unearned and it doesn't feel out of the
blue like unexpected and because of that
I feel like the small tour the small and
big story changes that they're making
are very necessary and like like you
said it feels like it makes a lot of
sense right now yeah
Nick how about for you I know you were
saying there are some things you didn't
like was any of this stuff not did it
not work for you at all I mean I you
know I I don't think my I'll take about
the ending is anything that could be
unexpected I felt like we're here for
yeah I felt like a I felt like they were
conflicted about about how to go about
writing the story and so the whispers
the Dementors right mm-hmm they they
come in they come in and in fact effect
the story when things don't follow the
original so in the very beginning when
you see him for the first time they are
making sure that cloud and Aerith meet
and then they bring Barrett back to life
at the very end I I feel like they were
a metaphor for angry internet fans who
made sure the original was exactly or
that the remake was exactly what the
original was and and
I like I don't I don't disagree with
changing things I think it's totally
fine to do that and and to an extent I
welcome it I just wish that they just
done it that they just made the changes
and not had to include some kind of
otherworldly element to justify it
yeah I sort it didn't I I kind of got
that vibe where when they explained like
oh they're there to make sure like fate
stays the way it is it was sort of like
oh is this sort of like meant to be like
a weird like this game can also exist at
the same time as the other one and it's
like an alternate like yeah like they're
changing things but they have like a in
universe reason for it is sort of like
yeah like I was kind of thinking that in
my head and I'm not 100% sure if that's
exactly what it is but that's my
interpretation too but then at the end
they also like defeat them and they're
like we'll make our own fate which could
almost imply like that that gives them
license to be more dramatically
different in the last episode yeah I
mean I think that's what the plan is
yeah this feels like the Kelvin time
line to use to borrow a Star Trek thing
exactly the JJ Abrams reboot and we're
in a different universe now and things
could go completely differently and I'm
kind of here for it like yeah yeah I
mean like I realize this isn't gonna you
know say she or comfort anyone that
already feels away about this but like
the original version exists man like if
that's the story you want it's there for
you to have any time you can twenty
dollars it's 20 yeah it's dirty you can
buy on if you can make it run on your
microwave at this point that story that
badly it's there for you I realize
there's some concerns about it but like
let's let's see what they could do if
they this is a game of our modernizing
final fantasy let's give them the
opportunity to do that and try and tell
a different but familiar story like
that's what my main takeaway with from
this game was and all we can do is
reverse of how we feel about it we can
only give them the benefit of the doubt
based on what they've presented us here
and if you're like us or like me
specifically I think they've not the
story out of the
in this game so I have AI with that in
mind like I'm I have to give them the
benefit of the doubt when they start
doing this I can only be optimistic
about where they go from this and assume
that they will they have a plan and they
will work that plan and that the
original Final Fantasy is there for me
whenever I want err
I just want to see something different
I'm excited to see something new and
there's some things happening here that
are both I completely understand it is
terrifying I think one of the other
things that people are constantly
bringing up is oh this is this is
Tatsuya Nomura on his [ __ ] again
during his Kingdom Hearts thing and no
more is it was a interesting writer his
influence on a game is interesting I
can't say I'm an unashamed fan of
Kingdom Hearts I reviewed Kingdom Hearts
as well I understand that the story in
Kingdom Hearts is like it's kind of
nonsense and good and I say as much in
my review of three but I also say that
it's got heart to it and I love that
element of it but honestly I would wager
he given the quality of the story here I
don't think he has as much power as
people think he has right now I think
he's definitely within square he's
definitely a important figure and he's
definitely a key creative decision maker
in this game but I feel like the
storytelling isn't his own like he could
not pull out this game right this game
the way it's written I feel like there's
way more people and what we're doing by
saying ice Nomura only and he's gonna
screw up we are doing an incredible
disrespect to every other person that
has contributed to that game and has
clearly like this there's fans on this
team you know there's fans on this team
you can feel the passion in there and
it's not a cynically made written story
so with that in mind like I just I just
have to give them benefits now having
said let me yeah let me introduce a
counterpoint to that and I it's it's it
could be a very minor thing but it also
could be a very big thing so there's a
point where Sephiroth bring
cloud to quote the edge of creation
unquote and I think it's right after
that where he says lend me your strength
which if you guys remember is like what
he says to Sora when you fight him in
Kingdom Hearts 2 yeah and my first
thought was oh this is like in an
alternate timeline cloud-like took
Sephiroth's and in that moment and
that's what brought them into the
Kingdom Hearts world even then the rest
of the series is like Tifa you know
going to search for cloud and these
alternate dimensions and maybe maybe
like Final Fantasy Versus 13 okay here's
what I think is gonna I think I think
Nick is Nick is writing fanfic right now
I am I love it represent genuine in this
belief that based on the ending of
Kingdom Hearts 3 and the recent DLC they
are making a cinematic universe for fun
and they're gonna they're gonna
intertwine Kingdom Hearts and Final
Fantasy 7 and maybe Final Fantasy 15 I
would get behind that if one of the
players in that in that story wasn't
Disney Disney behind I don't think you
can do also like I don't know III feel
like they can't could call a thing
Kingdom Hearts of without completely
like they can't do a Kingdom Hearts game
without having Disney involved in some
respect because they join us but but how
can you how can you explain lend me your
strength there's like even in the
context of the scene it didn't make any
sense it had to be if they want to do
that as like its own game sure I hope
that's not like where they're going with
the rest of the remake because that
would I mean like III it didn't it
didn't stick out to me as a as a like
really of place line I remember thinking
it's kind of odd but it also speaks to
what Sephiroth once write the reunion
and all that thing that they're
constantly referencing which is
something that will play out in a over
the course of these three or however
many chapters there are but like I I
heard that I was like oh he's he's
speaking about that reunion where all
parts are kind of
United again and that's what that lend
me your strength speaks to oh yeah I
don't know I can't I'm kind of into that
idea as well yeah I love that idea but
also if you if that if that happens it
will absolutely boil some Internet piss
like so holy moly
all right I have one more hot take about
the ending and all right this is this
could be a very minor thing but one of
my favorite video game moments of all
time and I think it's one of the most
effective video game moments in general
is when in the original game you go to
calm and cloud starts talking about his
backstory was Sephiroth and they
introduced Sephiroth when you see you're
on the train and clouds doing squats and
then the Train like runs into a monster
and then you and you and Sephiroth go
fight it and you control them both for a
second and you send cloud to attack or
something and let's say he does like 50
damage like he slices the dragon does 50
damage and then Sephiroth does it and it
does like 3,500 and at that point in the
game like the highest damage you could
probably do is like 150 something with
like my braver attack so it just goes to
show like holy [ __ ] this guy's is
insanely powerful so I didn't like how
whether the Sephiroth you fight at the
end of the game is the regular Sephiroth
or like the Advent Children
Sephiroth who's travelling back in time
there's no way that cloud is gonna be
able to beat that Sephiroth he's not
strong enough
hmm yeah I was gonna ask how you guys
felt about you fighting him at the end
because I was wondering if they were
gonna do it I was like are they gonna
have that's where they gotta separate
that's not yet to me that wasn't
Sephiroth that's that's pretty sure
that's like a duration of the yeah it's
a it's one of the Fate monster thing
yeah so it's it's one of the you know
they have those those characters walking
around with with numbers on them the
pieces almost I thought it was one of
those guys or
I interpreted - yeah we saw that two or
three times before then like one yeah so
in this game anova in this game
Sephiroth is never there he's just a
menacing presence that is there's
there's the different parts of jahnava
and like yeah he's he's able to he's
able to are being interpreted in us no
that's not true though because he
totally takes Genova at the end that no
that's there's a shot where he falls off
the roof and it turns into one of the
number guys yeah he's never in this game
which is why I was saying the way
they're seeding it is really smart and
really interesting cuz Sephiroth is all
over this game at a certain point but
he's never actually in the game we've
never met suffer off as we know
Sephiroth so when he shows up who knows
what state he's gonna be in and who
knows what level that will be in it's
such a smart way to have that code to be
there but also not overpower you
he should be in the northern cave right
like that's where no Sephiroth is hmm
he's hanging around somewhere
it's what is what was the aim but like
III just I think the yeah that I think
that that whole element was like that
that's the the lend me rmph is the
reunion thing and the fact that surfer
off is there and you kind of do him
about a bit is like yeah it's just it's
not him it's not him
yeah well I love the idea of them
building to this that all-powerful
moment where oh I was not ready for this
the entire time like oh like this wasn't
a lute like you know oh I fought him
before and then he realized like no that
wasn't even though the real him and that
was yeah interesting so I think the big
thing we should probably get to story
wise before we run too long is Zach yeah
yeah so I have no context for for Zach
I've given his name before and I so I
just like saw this and I was like oh
okay that's that dude looks like cloud
but he's not cloud and then I was I was
a little confused maybe you guys would
have more context for it yeah Missy was
that did that take place at the same
time as everything else because it was a
lot of those soldiers but it was during
the day and the the whispers were there
but then at the end it's him carrying
cloud and so I was like is that clearly
in the
asked but I was a little confused like
yeah timeline of all that if I have a
criticism of the story stuff barring the
the introduction of fighting destiny the
physical manifestation of destiny it's
the it's the it's the Zac stuff like I
feel like the game does a really great
job all the way through of like keeping
you up to speed with what it's doing and
you don't have to be like a longtime fan
to know what's going on in the story and
then the Zac stuff happens with no
context at all and it really felt
jarring it felt like a misstep to me as
far as the way the rest of the game
tells the story so I just say that does
it feel like they put it in because
that's a thing fans expect and they're
like well yeah I thought their fans
expected that at all like it to me came
very unexpectedly and yeah I saw that as
a character that is key to the story but
as far as I know he's not in as far as I
remember in it he's not in the original
version in a super large degree
you guys can correct me if I'm wrong
there okay just a simple flash yeah yeah
he takes like he's the main character in
crisis core which is the PSP game that
is a prequel to final 37 but his story
is crucial to the story of cloud and
Sephiroth I know
I'll let Nick explain why because I
imagine he's got way better
understanding of me well I mean honestly
tomorrow like I I've always been of the
opinion that like Zac was kind of
superfluous to cloud story like I get
you know there's you know talking
earlier about like sudden twists I mean
yeah without like I don't know I feel
bad John Lucas we're I'm no concept for
later on but like he's eventually
revealed that like cloud gives a very
detailed history of his backstory right
as it turns out that was Zak's backstory
and not clouds and in the original looks
like oh it was Zach the whole time it
wasn't cloud but it doesn't doesn't
really add that much to his character
yeah I feel like you could take out Zach
and and the story still works
and does it feel like they're retro
actively trying to make that yeah
I've never played Crisis Core so I I
feel like you I'm miss I'm missing that
context so crisis caused a really
interesting game mechanically and in
terms of storytelling it's it doesn't
make it kind of fleshes out that element
of Zach and it's not more about how do
we how and not why but like it's about
their journey so it's like you you do
get to hang out with cloud in his early
days and before when Hebrew friend Zach
and you get to see Zach on like equal
ground and equal footing with Zephyr
often and various other member members
of soldier and the Turks kind of feeding
into it and you the game kind of is
designed to explain why there's that
bleeding effect between Zach and cloud
but it still very much felt like a
self-contained story even though it was
a prequel that led into the events of
Final Fantasy 7 this feels like it's a
little more of an attempt to weave the
important parts of Zach into the broader
story and also maybe flesh him out a bit
more so I feel like they they are trying
to set up set up the character to be
more meaningful within the gray of Final
Fantasy 7 universe I think the tricky
part of it is separating their ambition
from the ambition where it's also
creating some sort of parallel
concurrent timeline that's the weird
thing where I even I having I mean like
I said earlier I finished the game at 4
a.m. and I was in a stupor I'd been
playing for like two days straight
trying to get the get ready for review
so like my processing of it it's
probably not great but it seemed like it
was telling two concurrent timelines at
the same time and we were looking at the
one timeline where you know and having
beaten the boss at Destiny's crossroads
it's not everything is unhinged now
there's no there's no accounting for
what's gonna happen in the future so
they're showing us two eventualities of
what could happen but at the same time
the more I think about it more I was
like oh maybe this is kind of like a
piece of the crisis core era story
just is unfamiliar to me and I don't
remember or is new for this it could be
like you know Zack and cloud
encountering the same kind of presence
that we are now but way back when you
know and it's another instance of
destiny weaving its threads to try and
make whatever is happening in the
current day but we're seeing it from
Zacks perspective way back when I think
that the thing that people are getting
caught up on right now it's it's how
different it is and because of that like
and and because of it it seems quite
outlandish compared to the rest of the
story which feels way more grounded by
Final Fantasy standards I think that's
thing something that people are getting
hung up on but I kind of maybe I'm being
too optimistic I could see a way for
them to make it work and make you
interesting if it was like we're gonna
fold in crisis call into this mean you
know three chapters or however many
years I'm kind of into the idea kind of
like the idea again it goes back to what
I saying before like we've we've got the
original Final Fantasy seven we've got
the original Crisis Core let's try and
do something different let's see what
they can do and see where it goes yeah I
mean that you kind of said what I sort
of spoke to earlier where I was like the
beginning did such a good job kind of
taming things and just being simple and
setting it up to that when it does get
to chapter 18 and it does become like
full-on crazy Final Fantasy nonsense at
moments it like I definitely felt a
weird a little bit of a disconnect I was
like okay this feels very different but
again I was like the rest of it had sold
me to the point where I was like okay
you know what I'm here for it I'm on for
the ride I'm curious if I can still feel
that momentum in later episodes like I
kind of wonder if they'll maybe dial it
back down a bit and and and then kind of
ramp it back up again like I got I'm so
curious yeah how they're gonna handle it
until these other parts I again maybe
I'm being optimistic and I'm trying to
be glass half-full with it because
they've earned it in this but I think
there are elements of the story that
they've seeded that require a little
more grounded yes to it and certainly
create the opportunity for them to take
a similar like not out of this world
old crazy tact when they write it these
things like the Wutai stuff they'll need
to introduce yuffie at some point and
they'll need to introduce that character
and explore the history the war between
Wu tie and Shinra and that kind of stuff
and the impact it had on the wall around
them and I feel like that's going to be
a big part of the next chapter in this
game in this series and I'm optimistic
or I'm hoping that they strike a similar
balance where it's like largely a
grounded story but it has this
undercurrent of something more
supernatural fantastical and fantasy
happening underneath it and that will
come - it's a more more natural
conclusion and crescendo in the final
chapter yeah
well cuz at the ending like after all
that craziness happens and it's like
playing the final cutscene it does go
back and it shows all the people of
Midgar like you know it shows the people
of sector 7 like starting to slowly
rebuild and they kind of like prop up
the you know the bar sign and it shows
like the orphanage and it felt like it
was sort of like taking a step back and
reminding you where this all started and
kind of like the driving force and I
feel like as long as the game the
narrative can still keep it grounded in
that aspect of like this is what it's
all for it's all for helping the common
people and it's all for like this
original drive to just have a better
world I think they can make the
craziness work as long as they like
retain that like that that grounded like
element of like this is why you're doing
it and this is what matters
you know barons doing it for a better
world and he's doing it for his daughter
that's nothing that I get yeah exactly I
definitely think that like it almost
felt like hang on we got a stop and do
some crazy supernatural stuff to justify
where we're going next when we shift out
the game and like when we stop
straight-up retelling the story and
we're they were they were opening a door
and it's it's part of the story they
want to tell but not necessarily the
story they want to tell you know like
they have several is such a big
looming figure and has so much
interesting weird lore surrounding him
already you don't need necessarily more
of that than there already is so I
almost feel like what this was this was
like a functional move kind of a weird
one but to like do this big giant you
know supernatural bossfight thing and
then maybe have that be some kind of
undercurrent for the rest of the story
but really not be a main focus just like
it's not really a main focus here you
know like it felt like something had to
get out of the way almost to me yeah I
feel like they is a table saying in all
ways I just I hope that uh they don't
trade interdimensional sci-fi for
stories like red 13 and his dad or sit
high wind and his wife Shira
like don't don't lose those side stories
that you know I Final Fantasy 7 what it
is I'm I'm sure they won't because this
game is any indication yeah I think that
that's what I was saying earlier like
regardless of where it goes I think
we're we can shoot I can and should take
some comfort in the major milestones
that they still need to hit or quite
grounded and they require them to to
take a step back from them the mat
matter stuff to to nail that stuff and
we're taking it as you know we are we
are trusting them that they want to take
a similar approach with this where they
do at least some of those stories right
and the moment you reach you know said
and you reach other characters like the
Wutai stuff and everything else that
Nick mentioned you need to you need to
do really in and dial it back a bit to
make that happen well sure I feel like
that stuff is gonna naturally serve as a
check and a balance for the for the
wilder ideas
otherwise it will just completely be mad
nonsense and it wouldn't having said
that there are also things in the let's
say the the kind of the milestone plan
that are also interesting and weird like
cat safe and yeah various other things
that
I'm interested in before like I don't
know if we're ready to move on but like
John Luke your your reception to a
strange blue cat briefly appearing and
then disappearing oh yeah that was yeah
weird that felt it felt like a thought
the Hedgehog character just showed up in
the middle of the scene like this really
dramatic moment and then there's like
furry anthropomorphic animals showed up
and then he like pounds his fist and
runs away until you reminded me I was
like okay as soon as I saw that I was I
got on slack and I was like tomorrow we
gotta talk about this kinda bummed me
out
I could have loved it I was like yes it
was funny I never liked him as a
character so like I was like such a sad
scene when you see him
like the plate is falling and everyone's
dying and I was like oh my god like this
is so sad like they visualized us so
well in 20 2020 and then you see Kate's
ears like thing is like I I think I
would feel I would feel more like Phil
feels if they didn't already start doing
such a good job it's not explaining but
the character that is involved in cases
story like seating that character in a
way more interesting or more more like
in-depth way like just that character I
don't want to speak I realize we're in a
spoiler this thing but like jean-luc is
probably yeah he has no idea and I don't
want to ruin this game represents a
weird situation in which you have two
levels of spoilers I was gonna ask you
guys what do you guys think I should
play the original now or should I just
wait because I I do I I sort of I've
been there was a part of me that wanted
to play the original I never got around
to it before this came out but I sort of
am happy that I was able to have this
this kind of unique perspective of
having not played it and just
experiencing it as its own thing but I'm
kind of all in on the universe and the
characters now
like I really like this game a whole lot
and I love these characters and I'm
sitting here being like yeah I could
wait two plus years for the next part
and like who knows it just played the
original like I don't know I what are
you guys I think I'm about to spring for
a new copy of ff7 I'm totally going to
do that so I think I think you are in a
good position to play it now I think you
saw I was speaking to willpower on our
social team and he was like I I want to
play the original before I played the
new game and I was like honestly I don't
think that's the best way to do it at
this point because you're not really
getting much out of that original it'll
just feel a bit thin and it's not by
modern standards it's not up there like
I I think I've proven that I enjoy that
game but like it doesn't hold up that
well people who play it now and adore it
are people who have the nostalgia
already tied up in it so if it's your
first time through I feel like you're
better off served playing the remake
seeing what it has become and seeing the
kind of the things that are beneath the
surface of the original and then going
back in and almost looking at like the
the roadmap for what could become right
did the future yeah so if you are gonna
play it like now is probably your a good
position to play but I wouldn't say it's
essential I do
do things like things that were alluding
to hair like Kate earth and stuff those
could be amazing surprises yeah also
could potentially be ruined for you on
the internet quite because there's a
thing is like there are certain things I
know like I know of the the character
death like I know some of that stuff cuz
that just was like like I knew vet
before I even like you know that's
that's like welcome to the Internet this
person dies like that kind of stuff like
right right that's done grindin in the
internet culture and gaming culture but
yeah I mean it's just like I just want
more like I just want more I think you
would enjoy it I do think it will feel a
little bit more like reading a plot
summary of the game after playing this
yeah but that's not it's not - that's
kind of a shitty thing to say and I
don't mean to like seriously degrade or
to like go to be down on the the writing
of the original I haven't played in a
long time I loved it when I was younger
so like greatness all with that comment
but this is such a better realized
version of the stories what I'm trying
just to get across so like it's it's not
gonna resonate I don't think quite the
same way but there's there's cool stuff
there I like I said I won't already play
it I think you would have a good time
because and here's the other part of
this and you mentioned that character
death I do not think that's gonna happen
in this die I really don't I think
they're setting up a whole new shift
yeah I think I think the whole reason
that they introduced the whispers and
like killing destiny and fate was so
they could change things up I mean
that's like the way I'm saying no here's
the thing I I bet I I get what you're
saying I think here's my two scenarios
either it will happen and there will
present an a/b timeline where it doesn't
happen so people don't feel too bad but
I kind of also think that they will
reach the point where they're like yes
you can mess with destiny but some
things are just inescapable and there
will be this heartbreaking moment where
in every timeline she dies and you just
cannot stop it and and it will hurt much
harder this time I feel like the only
reason that he spent this much time like
building Aerith into this amazing
character like is the best opportunity
to just make it her way harder than it
ever did the clouds had visually
visualizations about like he's he's seen
premonitions of it yes that's know so he
I'm not saying he's gonna like know the
specific moment but he could be like hey
just make sure you don't flake you know
a little bit to the right yeah right
yeah but know things are different this
is like the final destination of final
fantasy like things yeah things are
changing I really think it's gonna be
different
whatever what if somebody else dies is
dead like no okay no I guess I think
it's gonna change up I think something's
gonna happen I just don't think it's
gonna be weak
I'm happen anymore I'm going on record
to say I feel like this that death is so
fundamental to this story that it
William will still be here I think it'll
still be there I think I think they were
they're gonna realize it in a because
that how that scarred a whole generation
of people and I feel like I feel like
the one thing they change now is that it
was it felt unfair back then it felt
like you were robbed of something not
only a character and a friend but like
you invested in upgrading this character
that is wiped off the table and takes
everything she had with her along with
her I feel like now we're a stage where
the thing that they'll do is make it
feel less unfair and I feel like they
can make it more of a narrative thing
people will reflect on the narrative and
the kind of storytelling
characterization loss instead of the
mechanical loss which is the one thing
that kind of muddled the feeling around
their original death are you guys
familiar with an old GameTrailers comm
series called pop fiction where they did
like escape they did one about about
Aerith and how there was like this
insane rumor of like you have to go you
know farm the perfect chocobos and you
have to go like be every minigame and
like it was like this 50 hour thing that
you could supposedly do to get her back
but it's not true
I think we should I think they should
make that happen
they should put that specific thing in
the game as like the Easter Egg to those
people I think that would be amazing
I'd only think about it only in that way
if you think about it like they need it
to happen to me to sell Sephiroth as
being this old oh yeah they need it no I
mean I I still think we need that level
of drama I put it but to know it's
coming I don't know it's you've got 23
years working against you that's what I
drew I do like what Tamar said we're
like by introducing the idea of changing
fate they set the seed that it could be
different so that they can then you know
completely ruin it for you by saying no
one but that not that one but that one
won't change I mean Barrett right
like and then they brought him back
obviously but they just want to show you
hey like we could [ __ ] your [ __ ] up just
the stuff they do with bigs and Jessie
and wedges well like Jessie went like
that that whole section plays out I was
like yo they dig again they're preparing
us this is a game about loss this is
gonna be a series about loss as well and
these are small potential losses that is
gonna prepare us for the big loss okay
but side note to that both bigs and
wife's legs does did well wedge we don't
know what the hell happened yeah we're
not sure that was ambiguous with him
that was kinda weird you you bring him
back to the tower
remember shelter and we wouldn't expose
kind of says hi and that implies like he
might die and then it leaves it sort of
ambiguous if he like dies and that was
kind of weird but Jessie definitely
definitely died yeah sure I think in the
original they all three just got crushed
under the plate right they were just not
even even hear from them again
yeah they just get it's just
unceremoniously disposed of such a
bummer I love them so much in this game
yeah yeah and like I imagine you love
them imagine how you're gonna feel when
Aerith oh I know they're I well that's
why like what if it was Tifa or
something like I can't handle it well
that's the thing is like I I always knew
about Erath and I know she dies but
again I had never played it so I had no
context for who she was within like 10
minutes I am like I am gonna be so upset
when she dies because I already love her
I immediately fell in love with her when
I was a kid I was playing fantasy 7 for
the first time and Aerith died I was
like oh that's too bad
but like I'm happy to Vista like
questioning be devastating yeah I I
really hope they do the thing where it's
like you can't escape this is fate no
matter how much we play with destiny and
put you in a position to play with
destiny some things you cannot escape I
agree I think the would the worst fate
worse than not her not dying is one way
they create multiple timelines
it's like choose who you want to die I
don't want yeah that's the one I don't
want that either but yeah I think it's
gonna happen yeah but man what what yeah
I'm what a game what game yeah yeah I'm
just so happy that it's I it's as if you
were to tell me that I was gonna become
a Final Fantasy Stan in the year 2020 I
would have been like what what are you
talking about that game developed when T
three years ago it's too late for me
there's no way I can like that game I
really thought I was over this part of
my life I really thought I was done with
the Final Fantasy fandom that I was I
was really a big fan in high school and
then I like to fell out of it I was like
oh these kind of like they're too long
and I'm not really into him and the
writing is not good enough and like
whatever you know I'm back I'm so back
into it it makes me feel positive for
square in a way that is again Final
Fantasy's just never grabbed me you know
like thirteen didn't grab me and fifteen
like you know those games have their
moments and their elements but they just
never worked for me and I figured like
these games to start for me anymore the
stuff square makes just maybe isn't for
me anymore but like this gives me hope
that like I'm excited at like what
squares gonna do next even outside of
Final Fantasy you know the remake of
seven like what sixteen gonna be like
now I feel like they have a great big
foundation yeah do I have to play this
MMO says if it's very very good yeah
that's why it's it's it's also upfront
60 hours of one the most boring game you
ever played yeah I started it and I'm
committed to playing it because of
Michael I am and how much he just
obsesses over that game vitally you do
have to grind through the realm reborn
stuff so that is yet painfully bad they
are streamlining it so it's worth
letting them finish streamlining that I
did it I got 40 hours in and then I
moved countries and I cannot access that
account again so walked out of that if I
want to do it I have to go all over in
the beginning but you know what I've
been thinking about imagine if they did
this style of remake
Chrono Trigger I know oh my god oh my
god
guys we didn't even talk about the
combat in this game oh yeah
like when they announced that like oh
we're gonna update the combat system to
fit amorem like modern action RPG style
I was like well that's it like what rip
this game but I think I think it's up
there with like Kingdom Hearts - I was
like the best I love action I think this
is the best playing file I've said I
said in my review I think this is the
best best playing Final Fantasy there is
definitely of all the ones that aren't
the very traditional turn-based like
I've that's been one of the things that
have never quite clicked with me with
modern Final Fantasy's is the combat
like I actually like 13s combat I think
it does some interesting stuff but none
of them have never felt like I don't
know there's always something about them
that just feels off and it feels like
they've been trying to experiment but
never quite getting there and I played
this and I was like ah they figured it
out finally it took him a while but they
finally figured out what they want
modern Final Fantasy combat to feel like
it feels really good
yeah and it's tight it's game is keep
off it keeps just enough from like the
traditional turn-based tactical menu
stuff to like feel it gets it gets the
feeling of that stuff across without
being like burdened by it which cause
like yeah those battles those menu
battles like they can get real plotting
and it just none of that is in this at
all it just totally washes it away but
it gets all the cool like thinking about
what you're doing making sure your your
teammates are like executing the right
moves and like paying attention to
everybody's positioning and stuff gets
all the good parts of it with none of
the drawbacks it's so good it was it was
interesting because in the in the early
game I I started using the hotkeys to
assign specific abilities or certain
characters cuz I was like oh like what
can I do to speed this up like how can I
make this more streamlined but by the
end of the game I stopped using those
entirely cuz I was like what do I need
to be doing in this exact moment with
this specific character and I kept be I
just use the menu every time yeah
yeah I spent a lot of time like once I
figured out the weakness in an enemy or
a target I'd I'd use like the shortcuts
because I knew exactly why I needed to
get out of it but any sort of unfamiliar
or tricky or difficult bowel I would be
very meticulous in everything and also
like when you're trying to do things
like unlocks specialization sorry using
the you know the weapon abilities and
that kind of stuff you need to be a
little more like handhold e and get get
involved and switch between characters
so and that requires a lot of
micromanagement in a satisfying way it's
a lot of fun I'm actually really
interested to go back and try hard mode
because I have a feeling that it's gonna
really make all those systems really
shine the way they work together like
you can kind of muddle through a lot of
the fights in normal mode like some of
them are really challenging how house
was really challenging like a lot of the
stuff toward the end that that fight
with Rufus was one of my favorites that
has ever in the game but you can kind of
like just you know let your guys do
whatever I have a feeling that hard mode
is gonna really like make all that stuff
mesh in a way that really shows how good
it is I'm really I'm really looking
forward to going back and playing more
fights basically agree hard much really
good even even guard scorpion is pretty
tough
no man no forty hours well right is
there any other noteworthy things that
we didn't mention that you guys want to
want to shout out about this this game
that we all feel very very strongly
about I think I've said everything I can
say about Final Fantasy 7 remake of it
are you tomorrow a lasting thought that
I'll leave with is they did it like that
there's no way they could have done it
but they did it it's uh yeah it blows my
mind yeah the phrase too big to fail
comes come to mind a whole bunch of
times one because like I I know I think
about it like there's a world where they
screwed this up was that even possible
not to undersell the achievement but
like I can't believe they did it man
they did it and like I can't believe I
loved it as much as I did yeah I would
say even if if the later episodes
don't don't hit quite as well I would
say I mean maybe my opinion on it will
change it they could it could if it
really should stew bad maybe my opinion
but I would say this there's like it
stands on its own as an achievement as a
game of Thrones fun I can tell you that
you'll be surprised how how impactful a
bad ending can be on the whole thing
that's actually a really good point you
know what yeah well well let's not think
I do love about this what I do love
about this is that it feels like its own
thing it is a chapter a complete chapter
one whole story there's more to the
story and sequels can like fill that out
but it's like a Star Wars movie like you
can enjoy any given original trilogy
Star Wars movie free of the like larger
tale that it's telling and I think this
is that too like it maybe it'll suck in
the end but it's not like episode 1 of
final fantasy it's like final fantasy 1
and then we'll get final fantasy 2 in
Final Fantasy 3 etc and so I'm happy
with that at least we have this it's
very good even if it the rest of its bad
this will still be good that's what I
think yeah and and the thing I'd also
say is like I know a lot of people have
some issues with with some of the
changes they've been made um and there's
a lot of people upset about what could
happen in the future
worry about that later man just enjoy
the game for why it is now like it's
it's solid it's it's amazing just just
just this there's so much to be a server
in the world just to enjoy something
just enjoy it and just enjoy way is
right now and if it turns out many years
five years in the future that that they
screw it up you wouldn't have at least
you had a time when you enjoyed a lot of
years you got a lot of years to enjoy
this yeah whether you've never placed on
fantasy or you're the biggest fan in the
entire world you're gonna get a lot out
of this game agreed
but hopefully you aren't watching this
to the very end if you've never played
this game hopefully she would leave it
first yeah I think that's about doing it
thank you everyone for thank you guys so
much for for hanging out for a good hour
and a half listening to us if you made
it all the way through the end you're a
real champion
you know I I had a really great time
chatting with you guys about this game I
think this is the kind of gillnet
like it doesn't happen that often but
they're there the gist those games were
I'm like I need to talk about this with
people I just need to sit here and talk
about these home and some scenes and I
was happy to do guys is I mean there's a
10 out of 10 game mm-hmm deserving of a
discussion it's gonna say it I was gonna
say it we don't we're very rare with
tonight ends but then we gave away two
this week both very very deserving game
very very deserving games like I can't I
couldn't see persona 5 a royal gain
anything less than ten anyway having
played so now that I finished that's
actually the next game I'm gonna play so
just gotta keep this JRPG train rolling
yeah so thank you again for watching
everybody
if you liked this and stuck all the way
through and aren't subscribed to us you
probably should and you know we'll
definitely have more if you like
specifically if you like the spoiler
cast please like let us know we don't do
these that often I think we kind of just
do it for games that we really care
about but if that's something our
audience likes and we feel passionate
about it we're more than happy to to do
stuff like this so please let us know
and yeah just I don't know go play Final
Fantasy start it up again
play play down hard to talk to us on
Twitter because yeah I'm I'm at two more
H come and tell your opinions to me mhm
at film earnshaw just one word smart man
talk to them talk to everyone else all
relay messages yeah yeah yeah you think
you can find the concerns to slack
you can find me at y'all except if you
want to talk to me about Final Fantasy
thank you so much for watching guys and
we'll see you next time
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]